(upbeat music)
- I grew up on Disney.
(laughing)
I always, you know, thought like, okay,
I'm gonna meet love my
life in high school.
Head in the clouds, you know.
(giggles)
(techno music)
- [Director] It was love at first sight.
Three, two, one.
(heavy breathing)
(giggles)
- I saw him in a grocery
store when I was 15.
- I saw her and she was
a, you know, a customer
and I was a stock boy,
and so I stalked her.
(laughing)
Aisle eight, the cheese aisle.
So yeah, I totally fell in love with her.
- [Participant] Beautiful.
- The whole entire school
year I sat right next to him,
and I didn't say not one word to him.
One of the last days of school,
we were just doing our work
and he started singing.
So I actually fell in love with his voice
before anything. (giggles)
- It takes us two years
for us to start dating.
- Mmhmm.
- We've known each other for
so long, since second grade.
I mean, I had several crushes
on her, like, growing up.
- Fifth grade, I remember I
really had a crush on him,
but then my attraction towards him, like,
wavered throughout the years.
But I think it was more of
like a feeling that, like,
the feeling of love towards him was like,
kind of always there.
- For us, we were 15
sophomore year of high school.
We sat in like, diagonals.
We would like, always look
at each other and make
eye contact from across the room,
but nobody like, pursued anything.
So that's why I kind of went to somewhat
'cause it was always there
but we didn't actually
act on it until later on.
- [Director] I said, I love you first.
Three, two, one.
- It was 30 years ago, you
don't remember? (laughs)
- Yep, I said it.
(laughing)
Yep, and then she said it right after.
So, I said it first.
- It caught me off guard, honestly.
Like, it was like, what?
Oh, I love you too. (laughs)
- I definitely said it first.
And then I remember, I was like,
did you hear what I just said?
(laughs)
(gasps)
Cause she didn't say anything at all.
I was like, oh no.
And then you were like,
yeah, I love you too.
(laughs)
- I think I loved her first,
but I didn't say it first.
I think she said it first.
- I probably did, but
I just don't remember.
- I'm more reserved,
- The moment.
so I wouldn't have said it first.
(laughs)
- [Director] You're never
too young to fall in love.
Three, two, one.
(sighs)
- Somewhat agree.
- Too young is like, I
don't know, five, six.
Before you really
(giggling)
understand what love is.
But once you're like, old
enough to start thinking
about having a boyfriend,
girlfriend situation like,
I think then you start to
understand what love is
and that feeling that you
get inside your chest.
- I agree, so I'm gonna move over here.
(giggling)
I feel like the reason I was there was
because I was thinking like super young,
but obviously no six year old's gonna be
falling in love. (laughs)
- Yes.
- But I feel like for me,
one of the struggles has been
like, losing the stigma of like,
being too young to be in love.
Where people are like, oh, you don't know.
Like, you don't really know.
But I feel like it's a
feeling and you feel it,
and it doesn't matter how old you are.
If you met the person
that you're in love with
then you're in love with that person.
- [Director] I always saw myself
marrying my high school sweetheart.
Three.
Three, two, one.
- I grew up on Disney.
(laughing)
I always, you know, thought like, okay,
I'm gonna meet the love
of my life in high school.
Head in the clouds, you know? (laughs)
- Yeah, I agree.
I'm a romantic.
So I always wanted to marry
like, my high school sweetheart.
I was always like,
I hope I fall in love
young and meet somebody.
And then I was lucky
enough to have it happen.
- My parents taught me growing
up, they had always said,
you know, like, make
yourself established first.
Get a job.
And then you can find somebody.
So, I think that's kind of why I'm here,
right here in the, in the disagree.
- I just distinctly remember
like, conversations with her.
I wanna marry you, blah, blah, blah.
Like, not really understanding
the weight of that.
But at the same time, it's like,
when you have something so
perfect right in front of you,
why would you mess with anything else?
- All of my family, they
all met in high school,
and married their high school sweethearts,
so it wasn't that it was foreign to me.
But I knew when I met him, when I would
write his name on my
peachy folder (laughs)
that's when it kind of came alive for me.
- I didn't think I would be married at 21,
which is a really young age.
Plans change.
And we decided that we were
gonna get married at 21 and she was 19.
- I mean like boys in high
school were always like,
not the best, you know?
Like, it was just like,
just young, we're so young.
Like I was like, am I
gonna marry this guy?
Like, I don't know.
When I was in high school I
did have that feeling like,
I was, I'm gonna marry him.
Like, even though we weren't
together, I was like,
I have a feeling like at the end of this
like, I was gonna marry him.
We're not married yet.
But eventually.
- [Director] There was a time
in the past where I thought
we might break up.
Three, two, one.
- Being in a relationship for a long time,
everyone gets in fights and
that's like a healthy and
kind of negative part of a relationship.
But, personally I view
fights and arguments
as kind of like building together with us.
Like, yeah, there were
times where we had, you know
pretty heavy arguments,
but I think deep down
I knew that we were still
gonna make it together.
- I feel like we went from being
children to being adults together.
Obviously there's gonna be problems,
you have to figure that out along the way.
And I think that being at the
breaking point, being like,
I don't know if I can do this anymore,
but then still choosing
to be together is what
makes you strong and is what makes you
realize like, this is the person.
Because a lot of people tend to give up
but I never wanted to give up.
And I was like, no, like,
I want him and only him.
- Why are you standing over there?
(giggles)
- I would always say like, I
had so much growing up to do
when I was younger, just
like, mental health wise
and just everything that,
at this felt like I was a
burden to you or that I was
like, causing you a lot of pain.
Oh my God, I don't wanna cry.
But, you know, like, just being a
negative energy in your sphere.
So I thought, you know, it's better for me
just not to be with you
so you could be happier.
But then I stuck it
through, you stuck through,
that's the amazing part.
It was like, you stuck
through and you like,
even through all my ups and
downs you're always there
to get me through it and
just were always there.
Even though I was just like,
could be really mean or
could be very negative,
but now we're in a better
place where you've like,
taught me how to grow and stuff.
So that's why I was like,
strongly agree, 'cause I,
not because it was never anything you did,
it was more for me to like, find myself
and not have to hurt you in the process.
- I mean, for our first
year it was, it was rough.
Like, we were just like,
ships passing in the night.
I mean, he was full-time
working, full-time in college.
I was going to school and working.
And the challenges of being,
you know, young, new parents.
And it was just, it, it
was a rough first year.
And I think there was a point
where we both, I, I think
that we both kind of thought
like, are we gonna make this?
- There was one distinct
night where we fought so bad
because I mean, it was
just a boiling point where
our first son, I had his right
hand, she had his left hand,
and we were tugging at him.
He's going with me.
No, he's going with me,
but we didn't wanna leave
because we wanted to be with our son.
- Yeah.
- So that night we actually stayed.
And that was like a
defining moment where like,
okay we're gonna work this out because we
have to work it out for our family.
- [Director] Building a family is an
important part of our relationship to me.
Three, two, one.
- I mean, for me, this is a no brainer.
I mean, growing up, I always
had this dream of like,
I'm gonna have this big family.
And it's almost like, I just
feel I'm living out this dream.
I mean, I know it sounds so simple,
but it is literally having children.
I mean, we've had a, we've
had a lot of losses also.
Sorry.
Yeah.
We've had four children here.
We have four in heaven.
And for us it was never
easy to get pregnant.
And when we did, it was such a gift.
(choking up)
Sorry, I don't mean to be so emotional.
But, my kids, my grandkids,
now we have a daughter-in-law.
I mean, it literally
makes my heart so happy
when I see them, when they
walk through the door.
I mean, I feel like those are
some of our happiest times
just when our children and
our family is all together.
It's just, it's amazing.
- Yeah.
- That is truly inspiring in so many ways.
Like, I truly wanna be like,
you wanna grow up. (laughs)
Right now at the moment,
like, you are my family.
- Oh yeah.
- I've always had a big family.
- Yeah.
- So that's something that
I've always inspired to have,
and I couldn't imagine doing that
with anyone else besides you.
- Me as well.
- The reason I feel like
we love each other so much
and stay together is
'cause we have envisioned
a future of building a family,
having a healthy household.
- Yeah.
We wanna be able to
cultivate an environment
and see how we do as parents.
I think that's what's so exciting
about our future is like,
how do we break any generational
curses and all that stuff.
- Yes!
- Yeah.
And just, you know, become
the parents that have
really healthy relationships
with their kids,
and so that's what I'm super
excited for in the future.
- Obviously, we live
with our family so our
family relationship is based on them,
but I wanna build one with you.
And like, obviously like, how could,
I'm so in love with him, like,
how could I not wanna have a kid with him?
So like I want have family.
Have my kids names picked out already.
Like, I've been there. (laughs)
- And have our own identity.
- Yeah.
- [Director] This is my favorite
time in our relationship.
Three, two, one.
- We recently went through a rough patch.
We're like, on the up now,
but I feel like, we're
still there kind of.
We're still trying to work through it.
So I feel like we've had better moments
but I'm glad that it did happen
because now it's only gonna
make us stronger and we're
only gonna go up from here.
- Yeah, and I'm gonna go with
just the cliche answer that
you know, every moment is
my favorite moment with her
regardless of whether we're
mad at each other, happy.
It's just always my favorite.
- We've like, lived in the
same hometown for years
especially like, after college.
And this past September we
finally moved in together
and that was like, the
biggest milestone for us.
We were like, finally like,
we don't have to travel
10 minutes to see each other every time.
(laughing)
Or like sleep over at each other's house,
but now we get to live
together and like, experience
every moment together, whether
it's going to the restroom,
like, sleeping together,
you know, you know.
(laughing)
But like, it's just I get to
spend every time with him,
and so I think that's helped
our relationship so much.
We get to like, experience life together,
and I think that's just
such a fun, happy moment.
And I think it could only go up from here.
- 34 years together is a long time,
so there's a lot of different
phases that we went through.
Like we have, we still
have two kids at home
and now two kids are out.
But when we had like,
the four kids at home
and just, just a family,
it was just so incredible.
And now it's just another
phase where it's just,
we have a lot more time
together and we can
do a lot of fun stuff,
but it's kind of hard to like to discount
all that other hardships
and, and some of the
really cool things that
we did in the past.
- There is nothing that
tops, that feeling of
when all your children are in,
you know, when they're home
or like recently we just had a dinner
when all our kids were
there and oh, that's good.
- Right now we are same
like, going through a
little rough path with my family issue.
So I think we spend lesser time from
what we used to have with each other.
- And I'm so happy, like we
are able to come here today.
We're in California 'cause
we're not from Cali.
So like, giving the chance to travel
and just live in the moment.
- Yeah.
- We have so much more coming
and so many more memories
that we can make.
But right now at the moment,
at the point of our lives
we have some stuff we
gotta work out, you know,
but at the end of the day,
it's more memories.
We're gonna get through it.
- Yay!
(clapping)
(calming music)
- I'm proud to be a citizen of my country.
♪ Proud to be an American ♪